[Applause]
oh my goodness i did it you guys
i did it
[Music]
good morning it is eight o'clock in the
morning and today might just be the day
that we get to meet this baby because
at 6 30 i woke up
with
my water breaking
like my water actually broke but
unfortunately i'm 36 weeks 36.2 weeks
you guys we were five days short of
being able to give birth at the birth
center so for these past almost two
hours like hour and a half um the things
that have happened is me trying to clean
up because this water just kept
trickling like the bag of waters broke
and it just kept trickling and so
got cleaned up took a shower as i was
taking a shower casey was calling our
insurance company because we still want
to
go to a hospital that can be like at
least like midwife led but then after
all doing doing all that we found out
that because this baby's pre-term a
midwife is not gonna see me i'm gonna be
seen by a doctor so it's pretty comical
how i was just so adamant about like
no hospital no doctor i wanted
i want a midwife i want a birth center i
want like the most natural physiological
process for this birth and because of
the fact that i'm this early it doesn't
look like i'm gonna get that so i am
honestly truly bummed but i'm trying to
like be positive and be like in good
spirits because that's important for
labor so i'm just like okay that's cool
all right today's what days today by the
way today is january 30th so i'm like
all right this kid you know gets to be
born in january
not in february anymore i'm gonna have
her earlier baby that's cool what else
have we been doing oh i did my makeup i
got ready um it's funny because casey
and i we've been planning a maternity
shoot and it's not until like two weeks
from now that's not gonna happen so
we're like oh my gosh let's try to get
some photos in like right before this
baby's born so that's that's why i did
my makeup i got a change we're gonna do
final photos and you guys might be
wondering like wait aren't you like
having contractions or anything i am
like a little bit but like
not even enough to be worried right now
to be like we gotta rush to the hospital
because from what i
understand from what i've been
learning once your bag of waters breaks
you have like 24 48 hours before it gets
really like scary
yeah we're packing because i did not
pack a hospital bag i don't know how
long i'm going to be there so now we're
packing a hospital bag because at the
birth center it was just going to be
like oh you know you come in you give
birth and then like four hours later you
go home i don't know how it's gonna be
now that we have to go to hospital so
we're like all right we're packing our
bags isaac's still asleep so we're gonna
call his dad and be like hey so i have
to go to the hospital can you take isaac
yeah we did find a hospital by the way
the one hospital that we want to go to
and yeah we're just gonna
finish doing what we're doing wait to
see for these contractions to get
intense because
my fear now that i'm trying not to be
afraid of
but just to voice it maybe it'll like
release it um is that
now because we have to go to hospital
now we're gonna have to really be
mindful and adamant about our wishes
about not receiving
like just to have an unmedicated birth
as much as we can because obviously
things go crazy it's out of our hands
but as as long as like everything's okay
you know i don't want to receive any
kind of medication any type of
interventions just like as natural as
possible but i know that that
is probably not gonna happen i have to
be flexible because of the fact that
this baby's pre-term so that's kind of
what i'm trying to wrap my head around
right now and trying to like
be like okay it's okay
it's okay we're gonna see our baby
sooner yay like a whole month sooner
and then last night it was so crazy
because
this baby was kicking
and moving like so much like the baby
was moving so so much that i even like
in the middle of the night i told casey
i was like because i cried like he had
his hand on my belly and i'm like do you
feel this
this baby wants to come out now like the
way that this baby was moving was like
this baby's trying to come out and i
called it and then a few hours later i
wake up because there's like warm fluid
coming out so i'm like oh my god i think
my water just broke so yeah that's
what's going on wish us luck
it is now 9
19. so it's like almost three hours
since the water broke
and uh tips having contractions but
we're still timing it we're not quite in
active labor just yet so playing it cool
and smooth and it's funny because tiff
was like you're totally frazzled right
now casey and i'm like i'm not frazzled
i'm totally not frazzled i'm you know
playing cool and smooth but she's
convinced that i i am i am excited
though i am super excited you know i'm
just trying to be ready for all things
but she's like just sit down and eat
it's okay and i'm like i gotta take the
towels i gotta get this and just just be
ready
i am excited though yeah look at this
isaac gave me this
for father's day one year
coming full circle
cheers baby cheers what's up isaac yeah
it's happening a lot sooner than
expected how'd you feel about all the
news and commotion this morning that's
pretty cool it's pretty cool you excited
yeah yeah you i think you're the calmest
out of everyone huh
you feel like i'm i'm excited you're
frazzled
everyone thinks i'm frazzled how is mom
handling it you think she's handling it
all right she's pretty chill she's
preaching uh only me i'm the only one
that's frazzled you know i'm timing
contractions
and the visualizations of that
happened baby
did you do something i was gonna ask you
if i could please
see if i could play vr
of course
sure you can in the meantime but did you
finish packing for your dad
okay i was saying that the visualization
for these contractions
is like in the movies when there's like
a parameter breach and then there's the
alarm sounding and it goes like
[Music]
like that's kind of like that's how they
feel
oh interesting like it like gets small
and then it gets like a little bit
gradual and then it goes back down so
i'm like cool and these are these
contractions are way different from any
other like braxton hicks or anything all
right don't hurt like these are like
a little bit painful cool
yeah so i've been i've been uh timing
them and they they're lasting
between like 25 seconds ish they're
coming every like
two to five minutes
okay two to four minutes
so like they're coming pretty frequently
but they're not lasting that long
yeah
i don't know i'm like oh my gosh this is
so cool so this is what labor is like oh
yeah this is your first two it's my
first time getting to go through this
i've already soaked through three
underwear
damn
two panty liners i'm gonna bring out
closet with you i know well the ones
that i'm wearing so luckily i bought
these period underwear preparing for
postpartum like bleeding because you
bleed for a long time after you give
birth i already like soaked through one
of those
and it's a super super soaker one or
whatever like the super
intense one and i have one left that's
in the bag that we're packing so i'm
like okay don't be soaking through no
more of these please no more water no
more amniotic fluid coming out we're
doing our photoshoot now it's funny that
this is what we're doing now oh yeah
this is the first time we're recording
our actual setup because we've been
doing this once a month
since three months yeah but we missed a
couple months oh yeah november yeah we
missed november yeah we gotta get this
going because the connections are
getting closer all right let's do it and
i i just keep trickling water so i'm
like
i don't know i don't know it's probably
not a good thing so we gotta do this do
it
[Music]
all right it is 1pm now we're still at
home
getting ready to leave though
everything's already packed up in the
car
isaac stuff is packed up ready to go to
his dad's i've been timing my
contractions and i've been having them
consistently two minutes apart but they
only last like less than 30 seconds long
and so i don't know from the things that
i'm reading it's like oh you should go
to the hospital when your contractions
are
45 seconds to a minute long so i'm like
man close enough we should head out
so
we're about to head out
are you feeling hubby very good
calm
cool
oh yeah you collected you're calmly
frantic it's so cute i could see you
like trying not to
stress but you totally are stressed
i keep watching i don't think i'm that
stressed you're also in denial
well i think there's definitely like a
bit of adrenaline going on yeah not
forever you were earlier like earlier
this morning you totally were it was
really cute shall we
let's go let's go
let's go baby
you're doing a great job in there keep
going keep kicking keep
making things happen
all right so at the hospital now and uh
tiff got uh and she's inside and she's
in triage is the term triage
and basically
she's waiting to be seen by a doctor to
basically figure out she can be admitted
here so the idea is to still give
vaginal birth but we don't want a
c-section and so we're already getting a
little bit of pushback on that like
they're already wanting to
basically say oh yeah let's get you into
the c-section let's get this baby out
and just put your foot down doesn't want
that and because of covered restrictions
on all that um
kind of stuck outside can't go anywhere
feels weird feels like i should be doing
something
but i don't think i have anything to do
waiting to be let in
to go see tiff just took my copy test
and
yeah just waiting i'm waiting here
went and grabbed uh our overnight
luggage and um
just i'm so bored waiting and it's real
cute that isaac keeps texting me and
calling me to check you up and see how
everything's going
[Music]
oh one second
okay it was funny because as soon as he
answered i had to put a thermometer in
my mouth
how are you feeling my wife
my warrior
[Music]
it's nine o'clock now 905 pm lots of
stuff isn't happening they initially
wanted to give me pitocin to induce my
labor but then i got an ultrasound and
they saw that the baby was
smaller than what we think so they're
saying baby's looking more like 34 weeks
instead of 36 weeks it's a huge
difference that's two week difference
and yeah like it's a big difference in
development too so because of that they
gave me a steroid shot
to help the baby's lungs be okay by the
time they come out and because of that
like the steroid treatment or whatever
it takes
i guess sometimes like there's two doses
and there's like 12 hours in between
each dose or something so they're trying
to like buy time for this to kick in
which means they're trying to stop my
contractions
so they gave me a pill for that and then
they're also upping my fluids so the
more hydrated i am the more they'll
space out the contractions today i'm
still getting some contractions we're
just gonna wait and see after the
steroids kick in or whatever i'm also
getting a whole bunch of antibiotics
because of the fact that my water broke
i'm on bed rest now i had to use a
bedpan for the first time in my life
which is so gross so i can't stand up i
can't i can't even like sit up fully
because then like amniotic fluid comes
out we need to keep that in
so yeah for the baby for the baby and
then i i was educated and the nurse said
that my body just keeps producing more
amniotic fluid
if it needs to which i never heard heard
of that so yeah i got poked so many
times like oh my god i got blood drawn
from here
they tried putting in the iv here it
failed and it hurts like hell they ended
up doing it here but they also the first
time they tried here
and then they just took out blood here
owie
so
just gonna have to wait probably gonna
be here for a couple days to buy time
for all these drugs to kick in i guess i
don't know it's literally so funny how i
wanted the
the most natural birth ever
and this is like the most opposite ever
well no i guess most obviously it would
be a c-section we're still hoping for a
vaginal delivery we don't want to see
sex but still like it's just like okay
i give up cool what else do you want to
put me with all right let's do it
it's an interesting turn of events
because at 6 30 this morning i was like
oh my god my water's breaking baby's
coming oh my god baby's coming going
through contractions here and there but
then there's space out and then they
don't last that long but then like the
ones i've been getting here and in this
bed they've been getting stronger so i'm
like what's happening i don't know
but it's fascinating though just taking
it step by step moment to moment and uh
hoping for the best you're lucky though
because you get to eat
that is true so lucky i'm starving how
how was them jellos yeah so i got two
jello snack packs that was my dinner and
my lunch i'm so hungry i'm gonna go to
sleep now i'm trying to because people
keep coming in all the time so i'm
trying to like rest as much as i can
while they're not in here all righty
good night
love you you're doing fantastic
[Music]
oh my goodness i did it you guys
i did it
[Music]
you